un immeuble à bureaux comme les autres
si ce n'est qu'ici il y à une corde pour
aller travailler une ombre pour dormir
et manger
chez reed ou de séparation afin de me
permettre d'être un peu tranquille est
un peu d'eau au moulin
depuis un peu plus de six mois fortune
obame vie dans les locaux de cette
agence de communication de nantes son
domicile il a ce qu'il lui faut ici li
salle de bain et cuisine est notamment
lorsqu'ils sont vides le soir et les
fins de semaine ses bureaux ont donc une
autre vocation
c'est mon super pouvoir être d'avoir
quelques instabilités la confiance de
d'une équipe et d'un directeur
d'entreprise qui voulaient seul l'accès
aux eaux locaux le soir et puis vous
avez une salle de bain vous êtes un peu
chez vous ça permet de pouvoir être bien
dans sa tête et plus de dire là
maintenant j'en twh est pas obligé
d'être à droite à gauche pour selon le
bon vouloir des gens
c'est pierre yves l'eau avec le
président de l'entreprise qui accueille
présentement fortune qui a eu l'idée il
y a quelques années de lancer ce projet
nommé les bureaux du coeur ont croisé
une personne qui dort dehors alors que
nos bureaux sont chauds il ya une salle
de bains les nouchis il ya de quoi faire
à manger suivre et mettre à ma place ce
serait tellement plus confortable elin
est venu là une idée qui s'est
rapidement étendu au delà des limites de
nantes salut fortune les bureaux du
coeur offre d hébergement dans six
villes dont paris et bientôt d'autres
municipalités à travers le pays
évidemment le projet a ses limites il
compagnies ne peuvent par exemple pas
héberger des familles nombreuses ou des
gens qui ont besoin de suivis médicaux
réguliers
les bureaux du coeur mais les gens qui
sont sur le point de réussir on peut
vraiment leur mettre le pied à l'étrier
et faciliter cette réussite est là
maximiser l'optimiser sûr on parle en
termes peu plus économique
entre employés et personnes hébergées la
cohabitation nécessite parfois une
adaptation dans les locaux de l'agencé
nobili tôt on assure que l'expérience
est réussie on entend parler de ça à la
télé mais discuter pour devrait être
cette chute de son parcours face à face
avec l'émotion qui vient avec en posant
vos propres questions sanaa ça n'a rien
à voir dans un cadre comme ça c'est bien
parce qu'on peut être les gens aussi qui
travaillent ici qu'ils peuvent aussi
vous apporter des conseils après un peu
plus de six mois fortune obama vient de
trouver un nouvel emploi
indirect son chevalet que des par
l'entrée dans l'entreprise
s'il a grandement apprécié le temps
qu'il a passé dans cette maison est
probable que les fortunes attendaient
patiemment d'emménager un jour dans un
appartement bien à lui il cira fait le
bouvier auclair radio-canada à nantes